so i'm like yeah yeah i'm going to start
the fight i don't know i'll follow you
down there so i'll drive down to the
last fight this is a little community
center conference center and i'm
standing outside the conference center
thinking should i go in or not
no one knows
no one's gonna notice i'm walking
towards the front door no one's gonna
know this no one's gonna notice i'll
open the community center door and as i
step in
i am literally the only white dude in
the room
everyone knows
i'm like
oh geez right the groom
the groom who i loosely know
that looks at me so confused like
i think he's thinking what's he doing
here man here he comes over to me he's
like somewhere and i'm like oh my
goodness this is the most awkward thing
he doesn't tell me i shouldn't be here
he kind of just like his confusion goes
to accept she's like
hi
i'm like oh my goodness i'm standing at
this buffet to this uninvited african
party
with his little plastic plate thinking i
am an idiot what am i doing here
and i'm there standing in the queue
and
i see on a little table
i see this lady i'm like
oh my goodness she's right there
i want to go talk to her
and i'm just going to find out her name
i'll have a little chat let's see what
happens
and i'm there i'm thinking okay i'm
gonna go walk to it now there's lots of
chairs in between and stuff but i start
walking over towards the table
and i'm like do you mind just moving
your chances a little excuse me
i'm making a commotion right
and i'm thinking i certainly have this
whole dread and i think when i get to
the table what's gonna happen i wanna be
like hey
excuse me excuse me like it's going to
be dreadful i have this horrible dread
and i get to the table i'm like she's
gonna really sit down
and i start talking to her and it's like
i'm like
and um anyway she's cool i say hey say
hey well what's your name where you from
and i stopped chatting anyway she says
that she's from leeds i'm like leaves
like l.e.d.s she's like yeah i'm like
that's my name
she's like
for like an hour
and i really like her i said hey if i'm
everyone leaves me but i can take up
dinner she says yes
i'm like man wow
took her out for dinner the following
week
three months later
i am madly in love
[Music]
and
fast forward nine months thereafter
me and amanda get married
to girls amanda
and
then fast forward another another 12
months she gets pregnant
we have our first child ruben ruby joy
ruby joy man brought so much choice in
my life and amanda's life
now i've got three kits
you know we just had a uh we've got ruby
we've got luke and we've got jessica and
sometimes i just look at my kids
i look at amanda with even more love
today than i even had then
and i'm just thinking
what would have happened if the talent
walked across the moon
that was it
walk across the room
what would have happened if i listened
to my little voices
saying she's probably got a boyfriend
you're a dominant
in fact i didn't have a little voice i
had a whole orchestra of voices at the
time
what would have happened
it's just one of those that was one of
those moments that i call a red diamond
moment
i've got a red diamond moment an
opportunity that presents itself you
don't know how it could shape the rest
of your life
until you go until you say yes until you
step out
and again that's that's what now when i
live my life every time an opportunity
comes along
a relationship comes along like a
business relationship
a joint venture a meeting
a training session
i can look at all my whole life how i
became friends with grant cardone how i
started doing dinners and stuff with
robert kiyosaki
my development deals that i've got from
my large deals my castle that i am my
castle same store right there
she was like oh yesterday you know you
bid it at like at the auction for that
castle yeah or the winning bidder can't
get his funds together we want to give
you an opportunity today do you want to
put down the deposit
yeah okay i will
and now as a result we bought the castle
for 800 000 pounds the gross development
value is 6.35 million
you know i'm like
everyone was saying oh it's a money pit
i'm like damn right it's a money pit i
made a lot of it
i mean i'm spending three million on it
i bought it for 800 000 the gdp 6.35
million and i'm getting more planning
permission for more houses to push that
up to 8 million
but
i was afraid i was afraid to do it
i was nervous
and you know what one of the things i
realized really interesting is i
realized that nervousness
some of you guys have been nervous today
you uh geo that came on stage and and
live you know you guys were nervous
some of you guys at the back of the room
registered for further training were
nervous some of you were nervous just to
come into this event some of you were
nervous booking on but more nervous when
you're standing in the in the foyer
nervous about coming in what to expect
but one of the things i realized is that
nervousness and excitement are the same
freaking thing
you know before you go on a roller
coaster and you're excited but you're
also
nervous
that feeling i love that feeling
somebody needs to start getting more
nervous
somebody to start getting more
uncomfortable
i'm always nervous
i'm always putting myself in situations
where i'm like
out my debt
and then what happens is
i push myself outside my debt and i grow
and i keep growing and i keep growing
and i keep growing and that's how i get
wealthy
most what most people do most poor
people is they don't stretch themselves
and they don't grow
and then they stay the same
but if you're not growing if a flower is
not growing then it's dying
so you're either growing and you're
getting better or you're dying and
you're getting worse and i'm glad to be
in a room with 150 people who are
growing and who are getting better
um a lot of people came up to me in the
last break
that we just had and they were saying
and it's so good speaking to people who
are making money man i've been speaking
to people in the break some of you guys
i'm so honored to be part of your
journey
um some of you guys are saying you do
rent to rent and
lease options
you know it's incredible man you know
who you're at and others that haven't
said that to me yet
and also respect respect for bringing
you sunbrella
respect how old are you
15 respect man
respect
you know in the world it's like the crab
bucket everyone's trying to pull you
down because you know what your friends
your enemies want you to fail yeah your
enemies want you to fail
i don't have any enemies you you if you
don't have any enemies you're doing
nothing
i have enemies
you should have enemies
an enemy is a competitor if you're not
disrupting the marketplace
then everyone will just think great
you're fine you need to have enemies
as soon as you start leaving your job
and setting up business and packaging
and selling deals and joint venturing
and people are going to start not liking
you you have enemies and your enemies
will want you to fail
will your friends want you to fail
yeah they want you to fail as well
your friends will want you to win
unless you start doing better than that
they are doing
so your friend will want to see you win
but not
so what your friends would do
is they'll be like yeah man they'll
cheer they'll cheer their chair their
chair and then they'll try and hold you
back because they don't want you to do
better than them
so what's the solution
find new friends
that are ahead of you
and they'll pull you up and then when
they pull you up then go find some new
friends
i mean you might be like sango and i use
people like stephanie stone or something
it's not my fault
i don't want to hang around people that
don't want me to succeed i'm only going
to hang around people that want to pull
me up i was used to being a crab bucket
and your environment is stronger than
your willpower
your environment is stronger than your
willpower remember that
if you're not hanging around people that
are winning you're going to really
struggle because this
look i remember i've met so many people
i remember when i met arnold
schwarzenegger
and they introduced him on stage and
said that he was a self-made millionaire
blah blah blah blah blah and when i
spoke to him in the break briefly
you guys know arnold schwarzenegger
right
he said that he
cringed when they said that he was
self-made i'm like what do you mean you
cringed when they said you were
self-made you are self-made you started
with nothing from a foreign country you
went to america with nothing you built
everything from scratch he said yeah i
didn't start with any money no one gave
me any money but samuel let me tell you
something he said no one's self-made
i am where i am because people put
opportunities in front of me and
supported me and i just walked through
the door i'm like wow that's called
humility
you